the nfl team based in the nation's
capital will now be known as
the washington football team the
franchise said yesterday
now this is not the final name or
rebranding of the team
it will use this name for now for the
upcoming season pending
the selection of a different one the
announcement comes after washington said
it would retire its previous name
following decades of criticism
that it was racist first on cbs this
morning the head coach of the washington
football team is ron rivera he joins us
now
coach it's very good to see you you know
on twitter there's a lot of
head scratching and a big hum about this
name washington football club i know
it's temporary
but it'd be like calling you head coach
man so i'm wondering this
are you guys close to making a decision
well good morning gail but um no we're
not close to making the decision
you know the biggest thing that we've
learned is that is that this is going to
take steps
this can't happen automatically so we're
going to have to go through the process
you know
on july 3rd we we mentioned that we were
going to go through a thorough
uh check a background check on on
everything and
and we found that it's going to be a
little bit harder than we had
anticipated
i believe with july 13th we came out and
said we were going to retire the name
and the logo
and then yesterday we came out and said
you know pretty much what we've done is
we put a placeholder in terms of the
name
so we are going to be known as the
washington football team because
truthfully this is going to be about a
16 to 18 month process to do it the
right way
and and really not not not miss the
opportunity to rebrand ourselves
hopefully for the next 100 years
are you planning ron to change the team
colors
no the colors will stay um one of the
things that and the big reason probably
is because there's so much tradition in
history with this football team that
you know to change the colors would kind
of distract from what this team has done
in terms of its past history
uh with the with the with the
championship said this one i mean there
was an era where
they won three championships in about 10
seasons so you know
we don't want to lose that part of our
history
you know a lot of fans are still very
reluctant for the name change were you
on board right away and how will you win
over the people that aren't ready for
the change
well you know initially i you know i'm
one of those i grew up with with the
washington redskins and i was a [ __ ]
fan you know
and i think the thing that people have
to understand is that this is going to
be a little bit of a transition it's not
going to happen immediately but
we're going to try and win the fans over
by playing good football more so than
anything else because
you know when you play well when you win
football games people get behind you and
they support you
you know we've got to come out and show
the show our fan base that hey we're
we're we're the same football team just
a different uh
name right now a little placeholder
again as i said but you know we've got
to do the things the right way we've got
to change the culture as to who we are
and really kind of not just rebrand uh
the name but but rebrand the the the
the style of football we're going to
play rebrand the way we do things and
that's probably one of the most
important things that we've got to do
right now
and let's talk about the culture for a
second listen you started this job in
january so
it didn't happen under your watch the
allegations from 15 women about
sexual and verbal harassment at the team
were you aware that there were issues at
the club before you joined
no no i wasn't you know again when i
first got there you know the biggest
thing we talked about was changing the
culture the way we did things and really
was with thinking from the football
perspective more so than anything else
but when these things came to light you
know we had to really look at ourselves
and dive into it
um you know mr snyder's continued to do
that he's hired a firm here in
washington to come and look at you know
the way things are done
and and recommend the changes that we
need to make so um no i didn't know
these things that had had occurred but
you know we had to make uh you know we
had to react when we had to do things
the right way yeah you know that's what
we're gonna we're gonna do
yeah you inherited ron what they call in
the streets a hot mess do you have any
regrets
about taking this job no no i don't i
truly don't gather you know i took this
job because of of what i saw on the
football team
in terms of those things you know who i
saw as the young players that this team
has and
to me you know there's a lot of young
quality football players that have a
bright future and we've just gotta
as coaches coach these guys up and give
them an opportunity to have success
you know roger roger goodell said
recently that he regrets how the nfl had
handled the issue of
players kneeling he has now reversed his
position on that
will you support players on your team
who decide that they're going to kneel
during the national anthem
oh most certainly again you know we got
to understand that that you know this is
one of our rights it in fact it's just
in the first amendment freedom of speech
and expression so again you know these
guys all they're doing is exercising
their fundamental rights and i'll
support them
because you know it's what our military
has fought for
you know for for freedom so again you
know i i think we've got to look at it
that way we can't look at it as any
other way
because i heard ron that you read the
u.s constitution the bill of rights
to to to figure listen it wasn't lost on
you about what needed to happen but the
fact that you did that kind of research
and this is what i've heard about you
ron that you know after the george floyd
uh
death you know it triggered a lot of
emotion it triggered a movement
and that you had a big zoom team call
with your team to discuss
how did you prepare for that
conversation with your team
well again i went back and i read the
constitution i read the bill of rights
and the amendments
um i talked to sports psychologists i
talked to
friends of mine i talked to a pollster
you know friends of mine that that you
know have these types of positions a
poster
i i talked to an activist who works with
the nfl
i've talked to some clergymen and i
talked to some police officers and i
wanted to get everybody's perspective
before i talked to our team our
organization because i didn't want to
miss something i didn't want to say
something that wasn't appropriate at the
time
and and one thing you know that did
happen too is in my conversations with
our owner with mr snyder
was that you know we had to do some
action we had to move forward
and we've been doing that as an
organization
all right ron rivera but you said
something very telling
you start playing good football it
it makes everybody happy it makes
everybody happy a lot of people cheering
for you
cheering for you at this particular time
very nice to see you coach thank you for
joining us this morning
we are pulling for you